it's amazing to meet you it is simply
extraordinary
maybe this will all make sense if I
explain Who I am my name is dr. Ellie
staple and I'm a psychiatrist my work
concerns in a particular type of
delusion of grandeur it's a growing
field I specialize in those individuals
who believe they are superheroes good
for you the three of you have convinced
yourselves you have extraordinary gifts
like something out of a comic book David
Dunn the only person to survive that
trainwreck all those years ago what do
you do I'm in security you think you
have superpowers
it's a feeling vision I have to touch
them you believe you are a protector
my name is Patricia I have no question
there are two dozen identities I'm Mary
Reynolds we almost got to roll that live
in that body with you to be it's common
any minute now for you guys but what I
am questioning is your belief that you
are something more than human and yet it
is true my bones break easily and I've
had 94 breaks in my life but you have an
extraordinary thank you this is not a
cartoon this is the real world
no way and yet some of us still don't
die with bullets
some of us can still bend steel I've
been waiting for world to see that we
exist may I'll meet the Beast I hope for
your sake that he likes you
that sounds like the bad guys taming on
a lot of people are going to die
don't do this are you ready
what do we call you sir first name mr.
lastname
[Music]
you